as at recording pop hey how's it going
red my name is Pierre ah
um I just have some stuff I want to talk
to your brother about um it's not going
to be edited it's just going to be mono
and mono mono a mono or mono al d'arco
and yeah um I usually do this kind of
stuff on friends with goodbye and I
lately I just feel like I don't know
where to fit it I don't know when I'm
gonna talk about these things and I
don't want to lose this you know
whatever this is you know what it is
don't you little turd
no yes me fine fine anyway if you're
willing to listen there's a few things
going on in my life that I feel like
might interest you or stuff like that
I'm going away for example the 20th of
March I'm going to Sweden sad to say
it's because my granddad passed away and
I'm going to say goodbye at a funeral um
I usually wouldn't talk about this kind
of private stuff I feel like it's a bit
too private but I wanted to just tally
bros that he had a skeleton cancer which
is a very painful cancer and he would
rarely feel like he was always bringing
him down a lot the pains and stuff but
he will one of the few things that would
make him happy was hearing from me about
how my youtube was growing or whatever
and so that would that was one of the
think few things making him happy and I
feel like you bros are part of that in a
way so I thought maybe that was a little
sweet thing to hear I'm sad he's gone
but life goes on anyway I'm coming back
to 24th or 25th of March so don't don't
don't think anything else if I'm gone
you know as you know where I am I can't
post videos all all the time this is how
it is even if I love doing it and me and
watts yeah my girlfriend
we're going to move to a United Kingdom
for a while but we can't we cannot find
a flat that we really like that allows a
dog we cannot do it I call them I musta
[ __ ] call it the same agency like 30
30 40 50 times every time I call them
that I is that guy with a dog again
ha ha ha ha I don't know why United
Kingdom it seems like you hate dogs for
some reason I don't know what's up with
that but we kind of gave up on it for
now
we still really like the UK um so we
might end up there some of the days but
we got an opportunity to go to LA yeah I
wrote down what I'm gonna say your Fu K
is wondering what I'm doing with it um
we were going to lay in in a month or
less than a month at the end of March
we're going we're gonna stay there for
one month just we got the opportunity to
go there and we're like [ __ ] it let's go
I'm gonna talk about more about this
later but I wanted to mention it I also
hope I can do a charity livestream while
I'm there um I didn't want to do a
charity livestream for so long as you
have no idea you had an idea well aren't
you special I love you for it that was
really awkward I'm sorry about that I I
can't scream here nearly because the
internet is not powerful enough
I'm literally paying out of my ass for
[ __ ] internet here so that kind of sucks
so I'm I'm hoping I could do that there
and we can show what the bros is all
about you know helping out charity
that's not something I forgot about I
totally want to do it and I we wanted to
do it for a long time so I'm excited for
that
ah I always want to talk about a little
bit about fan bases I feel like the Bros
has been getting a little bit of a bad
rep because of youngsters and I feel
like every fan base or whatever if it
matters I don't know if this stuff
matters to anyone but I feel like every
fan would have
those young kids that are kind of loud
and obnoxious and I feel like if you're
mature about it you would just be like
hey it's a kid you know what it's no
reason to be upset about it but I see a
lot of people getting pissed off about
these kids or whatever and I feel like
if you are so upset about someone being
not being mature then you could at least
be mature yourself and just realize that
it's just the kid
there's no reason be upset that's just
how internet works um that what happens
when you get 5 million subscribers I
guess I don't know I don't like it maybe
not everyone likes it but hey I
understand it's a kid I was probably I'm
nauseous as [ __ ]
as a kid as well so it's okay but I know
you bros better than anyone else
I feel like and I know II bros are not
old oh like that I know you bros are
cool people I I noticed it a lot in the
comments dude this is so much positivity
and stuff like that and I really really
appreciate that that's what I wanted
that's why I make videos for positive
reasons I'd like to talk about [ __ ]
stuff and problems or dramas that kind
of things because that's not what a man
thought but yeah um I also noted a lot
of other youtubers who's been coming on
to my channel I've been doing a lot of
collabs lately as you might have noticed
they've been given you bros a lot of
credit for being saying what I just said
like being positive and nice in the
comments so I really appreciate that
and so it's not all bad breath anyway
this is this video has been depressing
so far uh but yeah I just want to
mention it you bros are cool Saint cool
and just whatever all right
I meant no [ __ ] sense we've got a new
website as well um there's some cool new
features yet achievements for stuff I
love achievements so much it's kind of
cool it's comical you can't say it's
cool I'm using the website a lot because
I got suggestions from you bros
seriously so many awesome videos
from my channel it's all thanks to you
bros suggesting it on the website I got
so many suggest in there so if you have
a game that you feel you want to suggest
to me don't go ahead and do it on the
website I'll link it down below um do
not suggest me your favorite game and be
like don't do that don't do that
if you have a game that you feel fits me
then go ahead and suggesting but if it's
something like I don't know be Halo or
Carl of Duty that you know I understand
if people like but that doesn't mean it
fits me you know I'm saying you know
what saying you're all right mmm so yeah
I think that was it no there's also if
you bros one pip i t-shirts the ones
that I have on the spread shirt and you
never got one I feel like now it's a
chance to do get one because I'm
shutting down most of the shop because
I'm going to start doing selling them
somewhere else you can I think in I
think you can add a code springtime I'll
write it here add that code while you
make your purchase and you'll get free
shipping I think during a time period
that I'm not aware of right now uh also
I wanted to finally just say thank you
both for first of all listening to this
video I bet it was really boring
compared to what I usually do but I feel
like it's nice sometimes to just talk
you know I'm saying why do I keep doing
that but um it's nice to do that I think
you both appreciate it I hope you do let
me know what you think I'm looking
forward to go to LA I'm looking forward
to go to Sweden even though it's you
know um but I'm looking forward to see
my family all I
thank you for watching my videos I can
tell you bros enough how much that means
to me the fact that a lot of you are now
watching me for over years is insane I
can't believe that you brought stay with
me for so long that that's really I
don't know that means a lot to me so
thank you all of you you bros know how
whoo you
oh gee bros are and if you're new I love
you just as much you're beautiful I love
your hair today
what did you do put a pirouette in it
let's keep doing the pirouette I love it
I didn't like I gotta go eat um and I'll
see you later I copped about it ah